that means making sure our financial
services sector
traditionally so Nimble and agile
has the right architecture to provide
the best possible security for investors
as well as capital for businesses and
the best talent right here in the UK to
make that happen
the structures put in place after the
financial crisis have served us well and
financial stability will always be our
top priority
but we can further improve the
functioning of capital markets
so this evening I set out the
government's mansion house reforms
they build on the Edinburgh reforms I
announced in December and the vision for
financial services which the now prime
minister spoke about here in 2021 of an
open sustainable Innovative and globally
competitive sector
firstly I'm announcing a series of
measures to boost returns and improve
outcomes of pension fund holders whilst
increasing funding liquidity for high
growth companies
secondly I'll set out ways to
incentivize companies to start and grow
in the UK by strengthening our position
as a listing's destination
and finally we'll reform and simplify
our financial services rulebook to
ensure we have the most growth friendly
regulation possible without compromising
our commitment to stability
I begin with pensions
the UK has the largest pension Market in
Europe worth over two and a half
trillion pounds
it plays a critical role in providing
safe retirement income as part of the
social contract between Generations
government policy such as Auto
enrollment has strengthened it
but so too has confidence in the
expertise of our financial institutions
to manage Investments wisely
however currently we have a perverse
situation
in which UK institutional investors are
not investing as much in UK high-growth
companies as their International
counterparts
at the same time on their current
trajectory some Define contribution
schemes may not provide the returns
their pension fund holders expect or
need
whilst many defined benefit funds are in
Surplus their returns are lower than
some International peers and some are
still underfunded
so alongside our outstanding economic
secretary Andrew Griffith and Brilliant
pensions Minister Laura Trott I've
engaged with some of our largest pension
schemes insurers asset managers and
experts to put together tonight's
mansion house reforms
I'm also immensely grateful to Sir John
Simons and Sir Steve Webb for their
advice on how to construct this package
and I'm also very grateful to Gwyneth
nurse and her brilliant team at the
treasury Gwyneth is of course the real
Chancellor as we official chancellors
come and go
[Music]
tonight I lay out the direction of
travel
sometimes consultations will be
necessary
but all final decisions will be made
ahead of the Autumn statement later this
year
and as we make those decisions I'll be
guided by three golden rules
firstly everything we do will seek to
secure the best possible outcomes for
pension Savers with any changes to
investment structures putting their
needs first and foremost
secondly we'll always prioritize a
strong and diversified guilt Market
it will be an evolutionary not
revolutionary change to our pensions
Market
those who invest in our guilt are
helping to fund vital Public Services
any changes must recognize the important
role they play
the third Golden Rule is is that the
decisions we take must always strengthen
the UK's competitive position as a
leading Financial Center able to fund
through the wealth it creates our
precious Public Services
I start with defined contribution
pension schemes which in the UK now
invest under one percent in unlisted
Equity compared to between five and six
percent in Australia
today I'm pleased to announce that the
Lord mayor and I joined the CEOs of many
of our largest DC pension schemes namely
Aviva Scottish widows LNG Egon Phoenix
Nest smart pension m g and Mercer for
the formal signing of the mansion house
compact
the compact which is a great personal
Triumph for the Lord mayor commits these
DC funds which represent about
two-thirds of the UK's entire DC
workplace Market to the objective of
allocating at least five percent of
their default funds to unlisted equities
by 2030.
if the rest of the UK's DC Market
follows suit
this could unlock up to 50 billion
pounds of investment into high growth
companies by that time
secondly we know funds can only optimize
returns from a balanced portfolio if
they have the scale to do so
we'll therefore facilitate a program of
DC consolidation to ensure that funds
are able to maintain a diverse portfolio
of bonds equity and unlisted assets and
deliver the best possible returns for
Savers
tomorrow the department for work and
pensions will publish its joint
consultation response with the pensions
regulator and the FCA on the value for
money framework clarifying that
investment decisions should be made on
the basis of long-term returns and not
simply cost
pension schemes which are not achieving
the best possible outcome for their
members will face being wound up by the
pensions regulator
we'll also set out a roadmap to
encourage Collective DC funds a new type
of pension fund which we believe holds
great promise for the future
third we need to ensure that all schemes
have access to a wide range of
investment vehicles that enable them to
invest quickly and effectively in
unlisted high-growth companies
we've launched the lifts competition and
we'll consider closely the bids that
have already started to come in for up
to 250 million pounds of government
support
alongside that we'll explore the case
for government to play a greater role in
establishing investment vehicles
building on the skills and expertise of
the British business bank's commercial
arm which has helped to mobilize 15
billion pounds of capital into over 20
000 companies
ahead of the Autumn statement we will
test options to open those investment
opportunities in high growth companies
to Pension funds as a way of crowding in
more investment
I now move on to Define benefit schemes
which number over five thousand and
operate under a different regulatory
regime their landscape is also too
fragmented
I recognize the important role played by
insurers offering buyout schemes which
will continue to be an essential part of
the way we improve security for pension
members in this market
but in addition we will set out plans on
introducing a permanent super fund
regulatory regime to provide sponsoring
employers and trustees with a new scaled
up way of managing DB liabilities
having engaged closely with a range of
experts will launch a call for evidence
tomorrow on the role of the ppf and the
part DB schemes play in productive
investment
whilst always being mindful of the
second Golden Rule to protect the sound
functioning and effectiveness of the
guilt Market
fifth we'll look at the culture of
investment decisions and improve the
understanding of pension trustees
fiduciary duty across both DB and DC
schemes DWP and HMT will jointly launch
a call for evidence to explore how we
can overcome barriers and ensure a focus
on goodsaver outcomes
and finally government must lead by
example
so we'll consult on accelerating the
consolidation of local government
pension scheme assets
with a deadline of March 2025 for all
lgps funds to transfer their assets into
local government pension pools and
ensure greater transparency on
investments
to make sure we are delivering the
maximum benefits of scale
we'll invite views on barriers to
achieving better investment returns
across the lgps
as well as setting a direction that each
asset pool should exceed 50 billion
pounds of assets
we'll also consult on an ambition to
double the existing local government
pension scheme allocations in private
Equity to 10 percent which could unlock
a further 25 billion pounds by 2030.
today's announcements
could have a real and significant impact
on people across the country
for an average earner who starts saving
at 18 these measures could increase the
size of their pension pot by 12 percent
over their career that's worth a
thousand pounds more a year in
retirement at the same time this package
has the potential to unlock an
additional 75 billion pounds of
financing for growth by 2030. finally
addressing the shortage of scale-up
capital holding back so many of our most
promising companies
increasing borrowing through 28 billion
pounds a year of unfunded spending
commitments as some are suggesting would
entrench inflation and push up interest
rates
these reforms conversely unlock capital
from the private sector delivering
growth not by subsidy but by increasing
support for entrepreneurs and investors
who take risks to create long-term value
I now move on to listings
the UK has the largest stock market in
Europe and in 2021 attracted the most
Global IPOs of any stock market outside
the U.S
but between 1997 and 2019 there was a 44
decline in the number of domestic listed
companies in the UK
part of a wider Trend across Western
markets with the US and France seeing
even steeper Falls
I want the world's fastest growing
companies to grow and list right here
making lse not just Europe's NASDAQ but
much more as David Schwimmer and Julia
hoggett say we want it to be the global
capital for Capital
So today we're publishing draft
legislation on prospectus reforms
delivering another Milestone of Lord
Hills UK listing review
this will create a more effective regime
than its EU predecessor giving companies
the flexibility to raise larger sums
from investors more quickly
the government welcomes Rachel Kent's
excellent investment research review
published today and has accepted all
recommendations made to it
we therefore welcome the fca's
commitment to start immediate engagement
with the market to inform any rule
changes on removing the requirement to
unbundle research costs by the first
half of next year this will ensure we're
better able to fund quality Research
into the new Silicon Valley sectors
last week we abolished protectionist
rules inherited from our time in the EU
such as the share trading obligation and
double volume cap so UK businesses can
now access the best and most liquid
markets anywhere in the world
and in a highly Innovative step which
represents a global first we'll
establish a pioneering new intermittent
trading venue that will improve private
companies access to Capital markets
before they publicly list this will be
up and running before the end of 2024
and put the UK at the Forefront of
Capital Market innovation
finally behind all those plans must sit
a financial services sector ready to
innovate faster with Regulators willing
to support them as they do
we have one of the most robust
Regulatory regimes and some of the best
Regulators in the world
brexit gives us the autonomy to put
their skills to even better use as we
seek to become leaders in the inter in
the industries of the future
so I'm delighted that we have just last
month passed into law The Landmark
Financial Services and markets Act
which will ensure our Regulators have an
appropriate focus on growth and
competitiveness alongside their wider
responsibilities
the ACT unlocks wholesale reform of our
approach to regulation
and today I can announce that we're
commencing a repeal of almost 100 pieces
of unnecessary retained EU law further
simplifying our rule book whilst
retaining our high regulatory standards
alongside this last month I was
delighted to sign the UK EU Financial
Services memorandum of understanding as
we build a new relationship with our
European partners
they're working closely with the bank of
England to reflect on lessons from
recent events to ensure the UK has the
best possible Arrangements in place to
improve continuity of access to deposits
when a bank fails even if it's not a
systemically important one
and I want to make sure that we're at
the Forefront of Payments Technology so
I'm launching an independent review into
the future of payments led by Joe Garner
to help deliver the next generation of
world-class retail payments including
looking at mobile payments
we land new legislation to give
Regulators the powers they need to
reform rules on Innovative payments and
fintech services and together with the
bank of England we're exploring
potential designs for the digital pound
should we decide to introduce it
my Lord mayor Governor ladies and
gentlemen
pension industry and listings reforms
backed by smart regulation to unlock
better returns for Savers and more
growth capital for businesses
that's what today's mansion house
reforms deliver
British growth driven by British
Financial Firepower providing High
living standards and better funded
Public Services
with cooperation between government
regulators and business closer than ever
will deliver not just more competitive
financial services but a more Innovative
economy
more money for Savers or funding for our
high-growth companies and more
investment to grow our economy
this is the vision I set out today
let's deliver it together thank you very
much
thank you
so the chancellor Jeremy Hunt delivering
his annual speeches you might call it
the mansion house beach at the city of
London uh twin themes I suppose first of
all he tackled inflation and said
straight away that he is prioritizing
tackling inflation over tax cuts in a
Blow of course to those Tory MPS who are
clamoring for changes and comment that
we have a very high tax burden in this
country
um and also the second point he's making
is this agreement with leading pension
firms to put five percent of their
investments into early stage businesses
in the fintech Life Sciences biotech and
clean technology sectors by 2030. the
ambition he said was to be the next
Silicon Valley let's listen now though
to the governor of the bank of England
Chancellor
I think we can agree that mansion house
is the place to be tonight but we can
also sort of still live in the Afterglow
of headingley as well I think so so
we'll make the uh
it's got It's got to happen another two
times as well actually because so we can
enjoy those as well
I want to start by welcoming the
Chancellor's announcements this evening
which are aimed very firmly at
encouraging investment in the productive
economy
now since the financial crisis which is
now 15 years ago
we've seen potential output growth fall
in many economies and the UK is included
in that group
so a sustained and robust Improvement of
the supply side of the economy is the
only means to raise productivity and
thereby the standard of living in a way
that lasts the test of time
so Lord mayor I want to thank you for
all your leadership in this work I do
just want to go back to the work that
you mentioned the sustainable Finance
work that we did during the covert year
and I want to thank John Glenn the chief
Secretary of the Treasury because John
you really actually provided the drive
and Leadership for that work and I think
much of what we're announcing to tonight
is you know draws on and is the natural
succession to that work
but as you all understand the my
preoccupation is inflation
currently at 8.7 in the latest data
Consumer Price inflation is unacceptably
high and it is our job and we will do it
to bring it down to the two percent
Target
now the UK is not alone in this
there is I can let you into the seek
John currently a popular saying among
Central bankers
which comes from the Danish philosopher
Soren Kierkegaard
which is the only Danish philosophy
you're going to get this evening well
from me anyway certainly the Lord
mayor's got some more time soon to
paraphrase it slightly it's that life
can only be understood backwards but it
must be lived forwards
that's an important lesson as we do what
is necessary to bring inflation back to
Target
in recent years the UK economy has been
hit by a series of external inflationary
shocks
higher Goods prices in global markets
are into Supply bottlenecks created by
the pandemic
and then higher energy and food prices
following Russia's war on Ukraine and
its people
looking ahead UK headline inflation is
set to fall markedly over the remainder
of the year
this largely owes to lower energy prices
as last year's substantial increases
drop out of the annual calculation but
food prices should fall too as lower
commodity prices feed through to prices
in the shops
now while the level of economic activity
hasn't grown Beyond its pre-pandemic
level on a sustained basis
the UK economy has shown unexpected and
welcome resilience
unemployment is at 3.8 percent
which is right at the bottom end of
experience in modern times
and thus far the economy has avoided a
recession
now in many ways this is a good thing
no one wishes to see unemployment higher
or growth weaker
but the interaction of above Target
headline inflation with labor market
tightness and demand pressure in the
economy has made underlying developments
in goods and services price inflation
more sticky than was previously expected
and both price and wage increases at
current rates are not consistent with
the inflation Target
now in the face of these inflationary
pressures monetary policy has been
tightened
over the last 20 months we've raised
bank rate by nearly five percentage
points
some of that tightening is still to come
through the policy pipeline
and we expect underlying inflationary
pressures to recede as headline
inflation Falls
but the monetary policy committee is
monitoring developments in particular
those in the labor market in wage growth
and in Services price inflation
to assess whether pressures are proving
more persistent
that's a drummer on Kiefer guard we make
our decisions drawing on the evidence we
have as a guide to the Future
at the last MPC meeting that pointed to
the need for further policy tightening
we're about to draw that evidence
together again
it's crucial that we see the task
through meet our mandates return
inflation to its two percent Target
and provide the environment of price
stability in which the the UK economy
can thrive
and this is the best contribution
monetary policy can make to the
prosperity of the United Kingdom
now living forwards in a time of
technological innovation also means that
we need to secure the value of money in
a different way
and for the rest of my time I'm going to
talk about the future of money
I want to start with two important
foundations of Safe Money
on which the economy depends on the
public can trust
the first is called the singleness of
money
while the second goes under the term
finality of settlement
these two together ensure things happen
that we take for granted
the first is wherever we hold our money
and banknotes and bank accounts
banknotes coins
we can be assured that it all has the
same value
I'll come back to the case which the
chancellor mentioned earlier of what
happens when a bank fails
in the moment
the second Foundation finality of
settlement means that quite simply when
we pay for something we can rest assured
that it actually has been paid for
now I say this because there's a lot
going on in the world of money so let me
set out some of the developments and
where they may lead to
so let me start with those recent events
the failure of a number of banks in the
U.S and in Switzerland and the
consequence here of our resolution of
the UK subsidiary of Silicon Valley Bank
that did raise two questions over the
singleness of money
as Bank deposits our money
how far does that concept extend and
what steps need to be taken to ensure
confidence is maintained
now an important qualification to what I
said a few moments ago is that setting a
deposit protection limit 85 000 pounds
in this country
means that in the event of a bank
failure money held on deposit in a
failed Bank above that limit may not
retain all its value
and as was clear in March what happens
to the money of customers who hold over
that limit
and therefore the extent to which that
money remains singular
is less certain and depends on how a
resolution is executed
Now The crucial question that comes out
of this is is that sustainable
well we know now that the U.S
authorities decided in March the
confidence in the singleness of money
had to be preserved
and so they use something called the
systemic risk exemption for a number of
banks to extend the positive protection
which in reality meant taking steps to
ensure that all of the funds launched in
those Banks remain singular money
now the term systemic risk is important
because the concern they had was that a
breach of the singular's principle for
large deposits in One Bank
could lead to a much wider loss of
confidence in others
now in the UK we were able to resolve
the subsidiary of Silicon Valley Bank
without having to put that principle of
sing on us to the test
but the lessons were nonetheless clear
we must when designing and implementing
resolution strategies avoid any
uncertainty over what will happen
we must have clear ground rules on the
principle of singleness in the event of
a bank failure
and so as a chance to mention it should
be no surprise that as authorities we're
thinking carefully about this issue
doesn't automatically mean all money is
guaranteed
but we must ensure the rules are up to
date and clear
and its developments in technology both
our ability to make payments digitally
and quickly without queuing as a branch
and the speedier transmission of
information about the perceived health
of financial institutions that have
brought this issue into very sharp
relief
now that's just one example of how
technological changes can bring new
risks and of course new opportunities
so let me move briefly onto crypto
assets these can take two forms
currently one is unbacked crypto the
other is so-called stable coins
I'm going to repeat something I've said
a lot of times the former have no
intrinsic value they're highly volatile
and best treated as extremely
speculative Investments
the latter so-called stable coins today
are used as settlement assets for
transactions in the crypto world
but as currently organized they're not
robust they don't meet the standards we
expect to save money in the financial
system
and they both fail the two basic tests
of singleness and supplement finality so
they're not money in that sense
now much more promising in my view is
the prospect of enhanced forms of
digital money which satisfy these two
tests
and this is perfectly possible and
perfectly achievable
now let me start with the question what
is enhanced digital money so I use the
word enhanced deliberately because today
we have money that's held entirely in
I.T systems so we have things that are
digital
so I Define enhanced digital is where we
have the capability to do a lot more
with it
to attach a lot more executable actions
to set things smart contracts up with it
some of which might be quite simple some
of which might not be
but the key point in all of that is that
we preserve the singleness of money but
expand the utility of money
and that's a great opportunity that we
have in front of us as I'll come on to
so the next question I would ask is are
we just talking here about Central Bank
digital money
well at central banks we do already
provide digital money to the financial
system at the wholesale level
but it is not uniquely true that digital
money must come from central banks
there's no reason to think that that
should be the case in my field it's not
the sole Preserve of central banks
a third question is is there a future
for this stuff
now I think the precise answer that is
we don't know
because we never know the answer to the
question precisely for new Innovations
that's the whole point about innovating
I would wager to say that more likely
than not the answer is yes there is a
future for digital money
and that we must avoid what I call a
failure of imagination
inability to specify a very precise
detailed use case today
there's not a good reason to think there
won't be one tomorrow
and let's face it there are all sorts of
stories around all of our skepticism
that we needed something that looked
like an iPhone before it existed and
actually if you go further back the same
is true of railways
turns out horses were just as good
so who might issue this new digital
money and might we see Innovation which
streamlines and hugely increases the
productivity of important parts of the
financial system
well I think the answer to the second
question is yes it is potentially a
major Innovation and one that we should
encourage
so how might all of this change with new
and enhanced digital money
well we're exploring with the treasury
the case for retail Central Bank digital
currency
there's a task force on cbdc which we're
jointly running and this is very
important work and we're very keen to
hear views and engage widely throughout
the project
we've recently concluded a public
consultation which has for us broken the
record of the number of responses with
over 50 000 responses
and I welcome that because the transfer
and I've always made clear
that the introduction of a retail cbdc
would be a major step
there needs to be an important public
debate about the future of money in the
UK
we also welcome a wide range of views
expressed in those 50 000 of what what
should come next
some of the responses indicate that
retail cbdc can be a real breakthrough
in the world of digitalization
others suggest concern about a desire by
the authorities
to reach into people's privacy which is
absolutely I should say at odds with
what we should do and indeed would do
and I will just say that whoever painted
no to cbdc on a Motorway Bridge
I can only apologize to the Cumbria
biodiversity data center I'm very sorry
about this that we cause this to happen
but from the bank of Indus points of
view our main motivation for a retail
cbdc would be to promote the singleness
of money by ensuring that the public
always has the option of going into
fully functional central bank money that
can be used in everyday life
and we've set out the arguments for why
this might be needed in the consultation
paper but we don't yet know
definitively whether we will need it
and that depends on how Trends in money
and payments play out
what I will say is that our work on
retail cbdc in no way alt Is our
commitment the physical cash will remain
available to any and all that want to
use it cash is here to stay
so let me go on to the mix of money in
the future
I don't think that we should be using
enhanced digitalization materially to
shift the mix of Commercial Bank and
Central Bank retail money towards the
latter
commercial Banks support credit Creation
in the economy
and I don't want to see this impaired
so we want to encourage more thinking
and action in the world of enhanced
digital Bank deposits
so yes I'm going to be quite blunt
tonight this is a call to action
particularly the banks don't leave us as
central banks as the only show in town
we want to be able to have genuine
Choice when it comes to digital money
now we may also get proposals to create
digital money in the form of stablecoins
news table coins
which could be issued by Banks or
non-banks and we will shortly set out
proposals for regulating these systemic
stable coins underpowers contained as a
Chancellor referred to in the new
financial services and markets Act
and these stable coins will have to meet
the tests of singularness of money and
settlement finality but they can do that
can be done
now I want to end by turning to the
prospect of wholesale enhanced digital
money and talk briefly about what we're
doing at the bank
there is in my view huge scope to
revolutionize the productivity of
important parts of the financial system
particularly in areas like settlement
and custody
wholesale central bank money which is
Accounts at the bank of England is an
extremely flexible and versatile thing
and it's an area where in my view we can
say with great confidence that we will
want to encourage an expansion and
enhancement of the use of enhanced
wholesale digital money
and we want to maintain the ability for
wholesale Financial transactions to
still in central bank money which is the
safest form of money to do that in
so we recognize that should they be
widely adopted
tokenized Financial Market transactions
will require this ability to
but as many of those in the payments
world have told us we're well on the way
to enabling this Innovation with the
renewal of the bank's real-time growth
settlement system
the largest infrastructure program the
bank has undertaken
under the leadership of Victoria Cleland
and this puts us in a very strong
position to deliver Solutions which can
integrate Central Bank digital money in
rtgs with tokenized transactions
and we think this is the fastest and
most efficient route to take
last week last month we migrated the
wiring of rtgs with the outside world
successfully
somebody put it to me we've we've moved
from copper to fiber optic
and I want to thank all the firms and
many are here tonight involved in making
this a success
what it means is that we have a much
improved messaging system with the
ability to transmit much wider data
which starts to enable greater
programming and enhanced domestic and
cross-border payments
next year we'll introduce the new
supplement engine
but the ambition doesn't stop there this
will create the platform for change in
enhanced digitalization
last year we consulted on what the
industry would like to see next in terms
of wholesale payment capability
and Victoria and her team are now
working with industry to develop an
ambitious and I will stress
world-leading roadmap of future payment
innovations that we will introduce in
the UK
this is all very exciting and it puts us
on the threshold of what can be major
changes
so let me finish with one force here
what the history of the city suggests is
that there is great capacity
to move on from past successes and seize
the opportunity to get out in front
again
and we have that opportunity with the
digital world
so we need to take it
thank you
so Andrew Bailey there talking about
future payment Innovations digital money
but our eyes were drawn to his comments
at the start on inflation Mr Bailey said
that the economy had shown unexpected
resilience in the face of inflationary
shocks Unleashed by covid and Russia's
invasion of Ukraine noting that the
unemployment rate stands at 3.8 percent
he said nobody wants to see unemployment
higher or growth we care but both price
and wage increases at current levels are
not consistent with the inflation Target
it is seen as a shot across the bow to I
suppose private companies and the public
sector not to push for or to to have
wage restraint uh Consumer Price
inflation CPI which he called
unacceptably high is 8.7 percent uh the
annual private sector wage growth for
the three months to April stood at
around seven and a half percent so
certainly wage inflation in his view has
been pushing or adding contributing to
the pressure on inflation he also said
he expected the headline inflation to
fall markedly over the rest of the year
because of lower energy prices food
prices should fall too as lower
commodity prices feed through to prices
in the shop so some cheer possibly there
leave that uh the Manchester Now speech
in the city of London heard earlier from
Jeremy Hunt as well the chancellor just
to bring you an update in fact from the
police concerning the incident at
Tewkesbury Academy they have now said
that the teacher involved who had been
taken to hospital with a single Stab
Wound has now been discharged from
hospitals so the victim has now been
discharged from hospital they reminded
us that they received a call at 9 00 am
from someone telling us about a threat
to a teacher at Tewkesbury Academy
minutes later they said they received a
call from the Amber